Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to see that some computer
graphics simulation techniques are so accurate,
they can come out to the real world, and even
teach us something new.
And it can do this too.
And, this too.
Today, computer graphics research techniques
are capable of conjuring up these beautiful
virtual worlds where we can engage in the
favorite pastime of the computer graphics
researcher…which is destroying them in a
spectacular manner.
Here you see Joshuah Wolper’s paper, who
is a returning guest in the series.
He was a PhD student at the time and his first
work we showcased was about breaking bread,
and visualizing all the damage that takes
place during this process.
His later work was about enriching our simulations
with anisotropic damage and elasticity.
So what does that mean exactly?
This means that it supports more extreme topological
changes in these virtual objects.
In the meantime, he has graduated.
So, congratulations on all the amazing works
Dr. Joshuah Wolper!
And let’s see what he has been up to since
he leveled up.
Note that all these previous works are about
simulating fracturing and damage.
I wonder what else could all this knowledge
be applied for?
Hmm…how about simulating glacier fracture?
Yes, really!
But before we start, why would we do that?
Because a technique like this could help assess
and identify potential hazards ahead of time,
and get this, maybe even mitigate them.
Who knows, maybe we could even go full Hari
Seldon and predict potential hazards before
they happen.
Let’s see how.
To start out, we need three things.
First, we need to simulate ice fracturing.
Here is a related earlier work, however, this
is on snow.
Ice is different.
That is going to be a challenge.
Two, we need to simulate the ocean, and three,
simulate how the two react to each other.
Wow, that is going to be quite a challenge,
because capturing all of these really accurately
requires multiple different algorithms.
You may remember from this previous work how
difficult it is to marry two simulation algorithms.
Believe it or not, this is not one, but two
simulations, one inside the box, and one outside.
To make all this happen, plenty of work had
to be done in the transition zones, so this
one for ice fractures might be even more challenging.
And you may rest assured that we will not
let this paper go until we also see my favorite
thing in all simulation research, which is,
of course, comparing the simulation results
to real-world footage.
For instance, the results would have to agree
with this earlier lab experiment by Heller
and colleagues that measures how the ocean
reacts to a huge block of ice falling into
it.
Now, hold on for a second.
We can’t just say that it “falls” into
the ocean.
There are multiple kinds of falling into the
ocean.
For instance, it can either happen due to
gravity or to buoyancy, or capsizing.
So we have two questions.
Question number one: does this matter?
Well, let’s have a look.
Oh, yes, it does matter a great deal.
The generated waves look quite different.
Now, here comes the most exciting part, question
number two: do Dr. Wolper’s simulations
agree with this real lab experiment?
To start out, we wish to see three experiments.
One for gravity, the color coding goes from
colder to warmer colors as the velocity of
the waves increases.
We also have one simulation for buoyancy,
and one for capsizing.
We could say they look excellent, but we can’t
say that because we don’t yet know how this
experiment relates to the lab experiment yet.
Before we compare the two, let’s also add
one more variable: theory.
We expect that that simulations match the
theory nearly perfectly, and to more or less
match the lab experiment.
Why only more or less, why not perfectly?
Because it is hard to reproduce the exact
forces, geometries and materials that were
used in the experiment.
Now, let’s see…the solid lines follow
the dashed line very well.
This means that the simulation follows the
theory nearly perfectly.
For the simulation, this plot is a little
easier to read, and shows that the lab experiment
is within the error limits of the simulation.
Now, at this point, yes, it is justified to
say - this, is an excellent work.
Now, let’s ramp up the complexity of these
simulations and hopefully give it a hard time.
Look!
Now we’re talking!
Real icebergs, real calving.
The paper also shows plots that compare this
experiment to theoretical results, and found
good agreement there too.
Very good.
Now if it can deal with this, hold on to your
papers, and let’s bring forth the final
boss.
Eqip Sermia.
Well…what is that?
This was a real glacier fracturing event in
Greenland that involved 800 thousand metric
tons of ice.
And at this point I said, I am out.
There are just too many variables, too many
unknowns, too complex a situation to get meaningful
results.
800 thousand metric tons?
You can’t possibly reproduce this with a
simulation.
Well, hold on to your papers, and watch this.
This is the reproduction, and even better,
we have measured data about wave amplitudes,
average wave speed, iceberg sizes involved
in this event, and get this, this simulation
is able to reproduce all of these accurately.
Wow.
And, we are still not done yet!
It can also produce full 3D simulations, which
requires the interplay of tens of millions
of particles, and can create beautiful footage
like this.
This is not only beautiful, but useful too.
Look!
We can even assemble a scene that reenacts
what would happen if we were sitting in a
boat nearby.
Spoiler alert: it’s not fun.
So, there we go, some of these computer graphics
simulations are so accurate, they can come
out to the real world, and even teach us new
things.
Reading papers makes me very, very happy,
and this was no exception - I had a fantastic
time reading this paper.
If you wish to have a great time too, make
sure to check it out in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!